I think we should have a debate on
health care it is a fundamental issue
for the Democratic presidential
candidates health care under President
Barack Obama health insurance was
expanded to cover 20 million more
Americans than before under the
Affordable Care Act or what's now widely
known as Obamacare but still some twenty
eight million Americans remain uninsured
and there's the growing issue of under
insurance
yes insurance companies are forced to
cover more people but if you actually
want treatment it will still cost you
Verdell Clark and her husband paid into
their health insurance plan for 30 years
but when she was diagnosed with cancer
she was still build a few thousand
dollars she didn't have her hospital
with Helder treatment and sued her at
one point authorities handcuffed and
shackled her as she fought the charges
in court
whatever the Hippocratic oath or the
first do no harm what I don't think that
a plan to 2/3 of bankruptcies in the US
are due to medical issues former health
insurance executive wendell potter says
that's because obamacare preserved the
principles of the u.s. health insurance
system to make as much money as they can
to bring as much revenue and but to pay
out as little as possible in claims
because when that happens they've got
more money to reward shareholders and to
enrich their executives the statistics
aren't in dispute the US has the most
expensive health care system in the
world
however when health system performance
is compared like quality and access to
care the US rates last against other
developed countries Potter is heartened
that some of the Democratic candidates
are discussing alternatives to the
for-profit health care system but he
says those candidates who want to keep
the insurance companies central to
health care in the US are often using
rhetoric he and other health insurance
executives made up in the board room
before funneling money to politicians
this America yeah but Americans don't
want to pay twice as much the problem
senator Sanders with that damned
building he wrote and the senator
and backs is that it doesn't trust the
American people the terms that are being
used today are the same terms that I
used to use and in fact in some cases
help create there's a term that's an
acronym that's used for this kind of
propaganda campaign it's foot and it's
fear uncertainty and doubt and these
campaigns are designed to get people to
fear change to make them feel uncertain
about what's being proposed and that
they would benefit from it and to doubt
those who are advocating it a majority
of the Democratic presidential
candidates are vowing to preserve the
role of health insurance companies the
strategy of a powerful industry honed
over decades appears to be working for
now she a burton c al jazeera
philadelphia